Talking about error is something that we do all the time in physics.
It's a very important skill to have,
but it's not as obvious or straightforward as it may seem.
Here, Plato's guess was 74,000 km.
The true circumference is 40,000.
Well, how are we going to state this error?
There are a few options.
We could say Plato overestimated the circumference by 34,000 km.
We could say the true circumference is about half of what Plato calculated.
Or we could say that Plato's guess was 85% larger than the true circumference.
Now, all of these statements are true, and they all talk about Plato's error
in making his guess about the circumference of the earth.
Now, my question is which of these do you think is most informative?
If we're trying to gauge the accuracy of Plato's guess,
which of these three statements is the best quantification of Plato's error?
I realize this is somewhat subjective.